[Musique]
moi
il est 7h doucement la ville s'éveille
[Musique]
doucement je crois que j'ai parlé un peu
trop vite
[Musique]
oh là là quelle panique
allez allait dépêcher en dépêchant
[Musique]
l'éviter pêche en dépêchant
avec tout le monde dans la rue
[Musique]
oh
vite quand on vit et qui a oublié ta
voiture
non ce principe et à l'usiné on repart
et au cours à l'école le naître n'aime
pas les retardataires au piquet tous ces
gens qui s'agitent ça donne le tournis
[Musique]
hu à tout va tout prend la place de la
girouette et c'est parti dans l'autre
sens vite toujours plus vite vite en
cabine
allez allez dépêchant des pechos
[Musique]
et on se dépêche de ça c'est de voir et
on se dépêche de dîner et on se dépêche
d'aller dormir
[Applaudissements]
heureusement la nuit c'est plus calme
[Musique]
moi je suis au besoin de recrues dont
leurs deux heures de sommeil en plus
[Musique]
dès le lendemain matin vis de moi allez
c'est reparti passionnante et puceau
j'ai dit allez les visites accord mais
n'ont rien compris à les retards bonheur
[Musique]
attendu
vous êtes en avance bien tabac soit vous
êtes à l'heure bravo les enfants à
naître n'en revient pas
[Musique]
et voilà la vie beaucoup plus agréable
quand on prend son temps et les soirées
sont plus tard
[Musique]
tiens mais qu'est ce que fait la
girouette d'un jardin ça y est la
famille non compris
[Musique]
merci à tous vas t'on grâce à toi nous
prenons le temps de vivre
au revoir
[Musique]
il